en niant ni qq bons soir benoît
poelvoorde merci d'être avec nous alors
vous voilà heures romantique de l'année
pour votre rôle dans le film coco avant
chanel film d'anne fontaine
vous allez donc passer une bonne soirée
vous aimez les récompenses ou pas
j'apprécie énormément les récompenses en
plus ses traits grossis me touche
particulièrement parce qu'être un acteur
romantique est une chose assez rare je
pense et c'est un prix qui touche
particulièrement oui est ce qu il est
vrai que vous ne regardez vraiment
jamais vos films après le tournage
et pourquoi oui c'est vrai oui parce que
j'ai l'impression qu'on travaille et ne
finit que après ça j'apprécierais le
travail de avec des ce que j'appellerais
des idées les choses qui perturberait
qui parasiterait bon jugement et qu'ils
soient liés
un peu comme si vous me regarder dans
une glace je pense que vous n'avez
qu'une vision de vous assez simpliste et
quand en fait fait partie d'un film
d'une entité est que quand vous vous
regardez au cinéma vous vous regardez
vous est en fait vous nuisez à la
l'intégralité du travail et donc en fait
vous vous pouvez tracer un délicat avec
le réalisateur qui a fait le film parce
que vous ne parlez que de vous sans vous
en rendre compte
ok tout le monde s'accorde à dire que
vous êtes un vraiment exceptionnel dans
ce rôle le rôle d'un homme amoureux et
ce qu'ils filaient il finalement il est
plus difficile pour vous de jouer sur la
sensualité à l'écran que de faire rire
ça dépend des partenaires qu'on a joué
remercie parce que si si j'ai reçu oui
j'ai reçu cette récompense je pense
aussi que je le dois à mes deux des
personnes qui m'ont permis de le faire
c'est-à-dire audrey tautou qui a été ma
partenaire et et à une trentaine qui
était marié à lisa tri ce qui m'a permis
de pouvoir traverser ce personnage
auquel on ne croyait pas moi même
puisqu'on n'a pas confiance en soi dans
ce genre de personnage
en tout cas pour ma part puisque j'ai
plus l'habitude de faire rire en même
temps c'est pas une question de facilité
c'est une question de confiance en soi
la difficulté de de jouer des
personnages amoureux c'est d'avoir assez
confiance en l'image qu'on ne veut pas
donner de soi et en ce moment ça va vous
avez confiance en veut un peu de peine à
l'accès à b monsieur j'ai énormément de
confiance en moi dans la mesure où je
sais que je vais faire la fête juste
après cette interview et je serai ravi
de retrouver mes amis
de fêter ma récompense là dessus je me
fais aucun souci
pardonnez-moi de plisser les yeux mais
parce que j'ai la lumière un peu dans
les yeux le chef opérateur est très déçu
mais mais sinon oui je suis en dehors de
50 euros on doit interpréter ce genre de
personnage pour ne pas faire des longues
phrases c'est toujours un petit peu
inquiétant parce qu'il faut faire
confiance à la personne qui est mon film
mais après vous regardez dans la
personne qui vous jouez si oui ou non
vous êtes plausible ou pas ou crédible
donc je pense que cette récompense me
touche profondément parce que c'est un
film sur lequel j'avais absolument pas
confiance en moi j'ai eu confiance en
font-elles qui m'a permis de le faire et
c'est audrey qui m'a permis de croire
que j'étais crédible nous le vend pour
moi même on sait que vous douter parfois
mêmes tout le temps je crois vous avez
encore envie de cinéma j'espère en ce
moment oui alors ça c'est beaucoup de
gens au murmure que c'est une phrase qui
était interrompu d'entre eux dans sa
durée parce que en fait j'ai pas dit que
je voulais arrêter ces images et pour
l'instant ça fait un peu le tour et que
j'ai rien de plus près enfin c'est un
métier tellement incroyable de faire du
cinéma c'est une chance inouïe de
pouvoir faire ce métier que de le faire
fatigué il n'y a rien de plus
dommageable en tout cas pour ceux qui
veulent le faire et donc à ce titre là
il faut garder une énergie et un
enthousiasme que j'ai peur de perdre et
à ce titre là je me permets de dire que
je m'arrête quelques temps pour pouvoir
retrouver cet enthousiasme sinon ce
serait cesser dommage quoi c'est comme
courir sur un circuit sur lequel vous
n'avez pas de zepa de plaisir à conduire
la voiture ça ça n'a aucun intérêt
c'est un métier qu'on ne peut faire
caler le plaisir est là l envie de le
faire sans enthousiasme les gens le
sentent vous savez où ça j'en suis
convaincu par contre je pense qu'on peut
mentir sur des tas de choses mais pas là
dessus mais merci à vous et à très
bientôt donc pour retrouver votre
enthousiasme merci beaucoup
l'édile a dit allez-y bien sûr pardon si
je me permettra de tout petits boj
devrait saluer je me permets de saluer
là vraiment et quelques secondes je vais
le saluer sa fille nebout qui est un
réalisateur avec qui j'ai tourné qui est
un grand fanatique de ce festival qui a
tourné deux fois avec eux la la la
présidence de ce festival est la
marraine de sa rivale qui est sandrine
bonnaire qui m'a donné confiance pour
pouvoir faire un film avec gérard
depardieu après qui s'appelle s'appelle
de la promo les appels signé dumas et je
voulais absolument en parler parce que
sinon la tâche est prêt à me casser des
ondes mais vous n'avez vous pas que
cette soirée se termine maintenant vous
avez bien raison vous avez raison et
profiter de rafic et là à deux chambres
de la mienne et je vous remercie de
voeux de votre attention je vous en prie
et à très bientôt
au revoir une petite carte postale n'ont
pas de cabourg maintenant